Apparently witch hunt and presidential harassment
are no longer good enough.
Raises for Donald Trump to describe a legal
constitutionally enshrined process called
an impeachment inquiry.
So Donald Trump is switching to racialized
language now calling the impeachment inquiry
a lynching this happened in yet another completely
unhinged, uncontrolled, unfettered Twitter
rant.
Check it out in its full glory.
Donald Trump tweeting quote.
So Sunday if a Democrat becomes president
and the Republicans win the house, even by
a tiny margin, they can impeach the president
without due process or fairness or any legal
rights.
All Republicans must remember what they are
witnessing here, a lynching.
But we will win some kind of white billionaire
lynching, I guess is what we are, uh, seeing
here.
Also just referred to as the proper consequences
to the actions of Donald Trump.
So there's a lot of stuff here.
I mean, every element of this tweet is very
dumb.
The lynching pieces may be the most absurd,
but let's go through it one by one.
I mean, Trump sends says there's no due process.
If anyone is interfering with due process,
it's Donald Trump and the people working for
Trump who are ignoring legal, congressional
subpoenas.
Yesterday, I told you about eight congressional
subpoenas that are overdue, um, and that there
may be no consequences for it that's interfering
with due process.
But more importantly, and this is a really
important thing to understand, the due process
piece comes if and when the house of representatives
decides to actually argue for the impeachment
and removal of Donald Trump, and there will
be due process, the house of representatives
will make that case and ultimately the Senate
will vote as to whether to convict Donald
Trump on impeachment, on the allegations contained
within the eventual impeachment articles that
his due process.
This is just an inquiry.
Okay.
And I saw there was actually, I forget who
it was, but there was a reporter on CNN in
the last 24 hours who did, it might've been
John Berman who did a good job of not letting
whoever the Trump official was play games
with this because due process is not an issue
right now.
It is merely an inquiry at this point in time.
Due process will apply if and when impeachment
is carried on and the Senate gets to vote.
So Trump's saying there is no due process.
That's not true.
He's the one interfering with due process.
Now, the question of fairness that Trump brings
up is sort of a laughable one, but if we want
to talk about fairness in a fair world, in
a properly functioning world, Donald Trump
would have been removed from office a while
ago for his endless violations of the emoluments
clause and money laundering.
Putting aside all other issues in terms of
legal rights, I don't even know what Trump
is talking about.
Impeachment is something that the house has
always had the power to do.
Republicans threatened Obama with impeachment.
They knew Obama didn't actually do anything
to justify impeachment and then incomes, Trump
Brown, noser Lindsay Graham after Trump uses
the word lynching, the Republican Senator
from South Carolina, and he also says that
it's a lynching, albeit a political one saying
it's a political lynching in every sense.
So I actually think it's not that useful to
focus on Trump's use of this racialized word
lynching.
And there's a couple reasons why.
One is if Trump is deliberately trying to
trigger the left by using a racialized term
lynching, of course, referring to the hanging
of black Americans, uh, at different points
in the history of the United States.
If Trump is deliberately trying to trigger
the left, it's not useful to take the bait
if Trump is using the term metaphorically
or whatever.
Although Donald Trump has not shown any evidence
that he can think metaphorically.
Um, it's also important not to go crazy around
the term because yeah, I mean, listen, Trump
being racially insensitive is not a new thing.
But as soon as the lynching terms started
becoming the topic of discussion, people pointed
out that Joe Biden used the phrase also in
a non-literal context during the 90s.
And then Joe Biden had to come out and say,
well, listen, the differences, I recognized
that that was the wrong word to use and I
no longer use it.
But you're immediately sort of muddying up
the waters.
It's important to understand that the real
issue here is Trump believes he's above the
law.
Trump, again, being racially insensitive is
not fundamental to thinking about what should
happen next to Donald Trump is president of
the United States realizing that not only
does Trump think he's above the law, but that
in effect he is, unless Democrats actually
do something about enforcing congressional
subpoenas, et cetera.
That is actually the most important thing
here.
Uh, Corey Booker is pointing out on Twitter
that lynching is an act of terror used to
uphold white supremacy.
And of course Cory Booker is not wrong.
All of the comments I've seen about the use
of the term lynching are essentially correct,
but this is Donald Trump and these are Trumpists
that we're dealing with and there is little
to gain from going crazy over Trump's yet
again another use of racially insensitive
terminology.
We are much better off and forcing that.
This is not a lynching.
It is not a witch hunt.
It is nothing other than a legal, constitutionally
enshrined process for attempting to hold the
president accountable, which Donald Trump
and the people around him are ignoring and
they may well get away with ignoring unless
Democrats do something about it.
That's my position on this.
We don't minimize Trump's insensitive use
of the term lynching, but we focus on the
fact that it is no, call it whatever you want,
lynching, witch hunt, whatever.
But Donald Trump is going to get away with
all of it unless Democrats actually start
enforcing their constitutionally enshrined
powers to investigate the misdeeds of the
president of the United States.
Now, if you disagree with me, I want to hear
from you.
If you believe that actually the focus should
be not on Trump flouting the law, but on Trump's
use of the term lynching, which I can see
it is disgusting, then let me know why.
Strategically that makes sense.
Leave a reply.
If you're watching on YouTube, send me a tweet
at the Pacman, uh, or follow me on Instagram.
We will have a post there about this at David.
Dot.
Pacman.
I will speak to you then and much more about
the latest, uh, day's news right after this
short break